welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Marianne certo who is a professor of
industrial environmental management at
the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies her research and
teaching focus on industrial ecology
circular economy waste management and
urban sustainability her research has
championed to the study of industrial
symbiosis involving geographically based
exchanges of materials energy water and
wastes within networks of business
globally she also has carried out many
studies of industrial ecology in China
India and other emerging market
countries as a way to value
environmental benefits alongside
economic ones today we'll talk with
professor certo about industrial ecology
and symbiosis in the developing world
welcome professor chert oh thank you
very much I'm so glad to be here let's
start with just defining some terms that
perhaps some people might not be
familiar with it familiar with
specifically industrial ecology and
industrial symbiosis well that's a great
place to start I'd like to start with
industrial ecology
which is a new ish interdisciplinary
field suddenly twenty years go by and we
realized the field is getting more
established Industrial ecology is about
the flow of physical materials and
energy through systems at different
scales so a factory is a system and a
city is a system we look at countries we
look at regions and ultimately we look
at the whole globe to ask the question
what are the materials and energy going
in what's going out what stays behind
where it ought to be or maybe not and
all of this is the study of industrial
ecology the study of the
use of resources and the transformation
of resources which makes everything and
human life nor could nature live without
the constant flow of materials and
energy mm-hmm and symbiosis so
industrial symbiosis we call a subpart
of Industrial ecology it's my specialty
and what I look at is the same idea of
material and energy flows but the system
is a little bit different the system is
typically a cluster of companies an
industrial park something where a group
of companies are all working in the same
vicinity more or less but they have
different inputs and different outputs
from their industrial processes and we
believe that by looking at that
carefully and understanding who has what
inputs and outputs we can create a lot
of efficiencies because we're spining
all over the world that even without
professors this sharing is being done
and with a little bit more guidance we
can increase the rate at which these
companies are willing to share and
therefore conserve resources and
sometimes even gain a new revenue stream
so if you're if you used to sell
something if something used to be
construed as a waste and now it's
construed as a resource then you can
turn that into a revenue stream okay and
I am curious to know what led you to
study this well I'll tell you the truth
a lot of my background before I became a
professor was in waste management and
that's in part because I grew up in the
area in the air I grew up in the arena
where waste and recycling we're starting
to be taken seriously
after Earth Day and so forth and I got
involved in that field accidentally the
way a lot of students do when they take
their first job I work for a recycling
company and I realized just how much we
were throwing away and how little we
were recovering and how much better the
world could be if we if we conserve our
resources so that was really the start
of that and what I realized about waste
is that you sim
they can't solve the waste problem by
only talking about waste waste at the
end of the pipe is at the end of the
system and in order to solve a problem
like waste you have to look at the whole
system back to the raw materials back to
the mines back to the way we process
things the way that we distribute
products and where they land all of this
is a big chain that has to be considered
if we want to reduce waste or not even
create as much waste in the first place
because we're able to put it back into
the industry now you have received
recently a very prestigious award from
remind me of what the agency is the
International Society for industrial
ecology right for work that you have
done with really moving forward the sub
heading of symbiosis so what are some of
the things that you have really worked
on to move that feel forward well of
course from our perspective were we're
interested in improving the principles
that surround these fields so that
people all over the world can can it can
and get engaged with them so let me set
out a couple of examples yet and then I
think it'll be clear we had the most
famous industrial symbiosis example is
in Denmark and what happened without
urging from the government or much other
external behavior the companies in this
small city of kahlenberge
figured out on their own that they could
exchange resources it was the same time
period where people were getting there
some dolt of environmental awareness and
a group of managers who knew each other
from the town who belong to the Rotary
Club whose children played soccer
together recognized that one company's
waste product could easily become
another company's food and so for
example there's a power plant that
has a lot of steam and so the steam
could be used by the pharmaceutical
plant and the refinery and waste from
those projects those industries could be
used in wholly different ways and so
pretty soon we had an image of rather
than waste each of these outputs was
being used in a creative way
sometimes with treatment so for example
the the air pollution stream from the
power plant could actually be captured
as a chemical that is the chemical
behind gypsum so calcium sulfate
so with this gypsum sure enough a gypsum
board company moved in and that created
economic development it created jobs and
it was more efficient for the company
because they could get their raw
materials from right next door so when
we really understood this model and even
the fact that it was self-organized from
people talking with one another that
gave us so much inspiration to say well
this self-organization is an important
principle and we should look for other
basic industrial clusters where such
things would be likely to happen mm-hmm
and and so that took us many years to
kind of sort out and make lists of how
efficient are these plants how are they
looking not only today but on a whole
lifecycle basis and that's one of the
important ideas of industrial ecology is
to look across the whole lifecycle and
how can you minimize the waste streams
and so indeed when we became better
researchers we realized that there are
many ways that this happens in
industrialized countries like China
where so much has made its you know the
factory for the world there we saw that
often times there was a lot of
government direction but it was the same
phenomenon that with a proper committee
and so forth then people could figure
out that there were good solutions for
companies and much larger industrial
parks than the ones we typically see in
other parts of the world where they too
could
and conserve water wastewater solid
waste commercial waste energy flows
steam all of these things were up for
grabs if we could do it right and allow
them to take advantage of the symbiotic
relationship of sharing rather than just
kind of ignoring each other in the in
the in this general industrial park
mm-hmm we for many years we visited
Puerto Rico because it's nearby
it has a strong industrial heritage in
these last 30 or 40 years and there we
could see everything sometimes there
would be a couple of guys driving their
Mustangs into the plant in the morning
and well they just got to talking and
pretty soon there was some kind of a
relationship of exchanging materials and
waste or sometimes it was more the other
where you knew that if you could take
ash from a plant that was burning things
and use that for construction materials
all of these things are beneficial so I
don't want to claim that we discovered
that these exchanges are beneficial
that's not the point the point is that
there are many of them that fly under
the radar that there are just companies
that are doing it because they can and
it saves them transportation costs of
bringing in material from somewhere else
and so what we've been able to do is
catalog them and to put shine the
spotlight on them and saying by doing
this we're saving you know this much air
pollution and this much water pollution
and we're creating new revenue streams
all of those things are important to
make them visible and so we've been able
to do that and of course when other
commercial operations see these they say
well maybe we could do that in our
system suffer in the area of industrial
symbiosis it's it really is something
contagious and it wouldn't it be great
if we could keep all that stuff in play
and not really have to treat it as waste
right right so
how far long do you think this the
United States is in terms of embracing
that I mean do you think you're
relatively successful in getting the
word out about how that works I mean do
you go out into different areas of the
country that are you know manufacturing
and and consult with them perhaps or you
know how are you growing the field in
that regard so I believe we're growing
the field but not so much in the United
States okay
the US has lots of land at the US has
lots of resources and we're working on
it where we have a National Science
Foundation study that we've been working
on for the last two years where we're
trying to match every County we're
trying to understand every county in the
United States and what kinds of
industrial facilities it has and what
kind of waste it has and we have some
great databases we're the only ones that
have them were able to create the GIS
that will show us but even then there
are always obstacles so that's an
ambitious example I've been very
impressed with what happens in emerging
market countries where waste is a
material waste is if you don't have a
lot if you if you're in a poor country
this need to throw out things is not as
is relevant at akai and so we looked at
a site in India this is our best result
ever in our research where there were 45
companies in an industrial park not that
far from Bangalore India you know that's
the Silicon Valley of India and just
because again there was some social
capital people knew each other they
worked on different things together they
had lunches and so forth that these
companies were doing a lot of symbiotic
things and because we were willing to
study it in detail
we actually got from all 45 countries
everything that's coming into their
plant everything that stays in their
plant everything that goes out of their
plant and when we added that all up
there was a million tons of what may
people would call waste and what we
would call you know material out of
place so when we actually finished the
analysis and saw that so much of it
actually was being recaptured by another
facility or sometimes within the same
facility that 99.5% of that million tons
was being reused or recycled at least
once Wow
I mean that is a circular economy it
certainly is and because industrial
ecology students at Yale are quite
adventurous some of them took it upon
themselves to find out where that last
little did they find out where was it
going well it was so interesting you
know we look we interview a factory
owner and he'd say well you know here's
how we do this and here's where our
materials go and that pile mr. Kumar
comes in at five o'clock and picks it up
well where does that pile go and so
first we have a saying in industrial
ecology that industrial colleges follow
the materials yes so my students were
jumping in taxis and cabs and following
these people through town and actually
yes finding out just what was happening
that even the way even the part that was
not usable by the 45 companies in the
industrial park was usable to somebody
right and the sale of that was what put
breakfast on the table the next morning
for their kids even if it was just a few
rupees say that was a great lesson to us
that waste has more value in a
developing country typically but also
that if you treat it right it at least
you can use the value that is there that
it is worth trying to make it happen
yeah so I know you're doing work in
Africa as well tell us what you're doing
there
well I've worked in several countries
but the one that we're working on right
now is in Rwanda okay and Rwanda there
were working on apparel clothing it's a
really interesting issue and I'll try to
explain it briefly but I tend to get
carried away when I talk about it
you you know from watching the TV and
reading the news that so many of our
Western clothing you know our clothing
that we don't want anymore
get shipped to African countries and in
other countries but East Africa is a
real place where they go is so many
articles and garments of clothing so
what we're looking at is some of the
East African countries are saying we
don't want this anymore we used to have
a modest amount and it was nice but now
there's so much which we do and Rwanda
is really leading that charge in East
Africa and they're saying why should we
take this clothing it would it denies
our ability to have a domestic market
and we want to employ all our people and
move up the economic scale so let's have
domestic industries and so they've been
working on domestic industries and
they've put a huge tariffs and the youth
clothing that's coming in from Germany
and UK and us and so forth so that's
discouraging a youth clothing from
coming in on the other hand a China is
very active in Africa as we know and
they have a factory there they also
bring in a lot of less expensive new
clothing and of course Rwanda wants to
make its own clothing and even has a law
called made in Rwanda because they want
to make everything in Rwanda so that
people can have jobs so you have this
interesting superpower clash at the
level of China and the u.s. because
under the trump administration Tareq we
had a little tariff battle about East
African clothing even so that's been a
prominent yo tool for for the youth for
for incentives there so we look at kind
of the you know the superpower level and
we look at the East Africa regional
level you know it turns out that
Tanzania and Kenya are handling this
differently than Rwanda and we want to
see if the very bold experiments in
Rwanda can work out and market that
clothing can be made at a market rate
that's affordable to the just some very
poor people there and so all of this it
relates to Industrial ecology because
we're thing
so much about reuse of clothing reused
clothing comes in from from the West and
of course the West thinks that's a great
economic and environmental solution
right but that's not how it's perceived
and so how well what else can we do
to close the loop right and and that's
really the part that brings an
industrial ecology of course we work
with development economists and others
who also want to keep track of the
economics but what a fascinating
application for us for industrial
ecology because Rwanda it says right out
loud we're trying to create a circular
economy where we don't have the waste
and we are reusing it we don't have a
linear economy but we have a circular
economy where clothing and many other
goods cycle right and that's the
exciting work that we're working on this
semester and what about next steps
well I think that what we see in the
future is an interesting blend of
technology high technology the need for
jobs going hate going wanting I just
came from a presentation about high-tech
knitting machines for apparel and these
are typically happening in Asia and
Europe they're very high speed you know
you can program them so they're very
accurate and making the the knitted
goods and and the speaker started out by
saying well you know when we cut a piece
of a garment about 30 percent of it goes
to waste and so I thought well there's a
big waste stream here but let's keep
talking let's keep looking at these
knitting machines and of course by the
end the Knitting machines are are
endlessly for you ask me about the
future you know they're there they're
there capabilities will go up their
prices will come down a little bit but
at the end of life and this is still
true because industrial occultists are
always thinking about systems systems
science you know always considering at
the end of life
there's 85% disposal to landfills
mm-hmm so you get these great knitting
machines
there's a bunch of ways you go through
the whole system of the supply chains
and so forth and then you still get to a
place where there's very little to do
and no one's you know jumping on it
enough to figure out what do we do at
the end of life when we're landfilling
so much yeah all over the world exactly
we need to start at the beginning and
say less is more less is more or let's
design a system not just an entry point
where these these types of manufacturers
can make money but you know and leave
out what happens to the earth and the
last part so I would say that these
kinds of experiences fortify me as a
professor and as former president of our
industrial ecology society to say you
know these are some open fronts we can't
look at these only and with this lens
but we need multiple lenses you can see
that although I've stressed the physical
side of this here in Rwanda it becomes a
social problem you know where do poor
people get their clothing and how will
it cycle to them right and how do we
consider these things that spring right
out of the question of resource
management right because resources might
get managed physically but then what
happens and that's where we interface so
much with the social sciences which
makes industrial ecology such a rich and
useful enterprise right right it
certainly is I mean you know I think
we're at a crisis point with so many so
much trash in the world and the oceans
plastic it's quite a problem so yeah and
it's getting a lot of attention right
now so you know you're interviewing me
I'm grateful but when people didn't
really care about waste and plastics and
so forth you know you kind of just have
a silent period for a few years and and
now it's just so fascinating to be the
phone's ringing the media's calling and
it's really the heart of that is not
having a systems approach to our to our
materials right exactly
well thank you so much for being here
and sharing some of your work with us
it's my pleasure I love to share this
work and you were wonderful too
thank you for more information about
professor certo and her research please
visit our website at macmillan report
yale.edu be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you